can we unpack everything that just
happened we can pack everything this
happened are we in therapy now I can
talk about it there were six of them
they were all here
oh that part that's very normal for me I
was like that was just a Tuesday night
or whatever it is but your dad reacting
to the Megan's all the Megan I didn't
see his face but I am very excited to
look at the photos of it I'm sure he was
quite surprised we did not know that was
happening so it's genuine shock and then
on top of that Jason Blum in Megan drag
Megan I mean it's unreal I and I just
keep looking at Lauren his wife who's
now seeing him in this twice so she's
loves it I love it it's iconic and
speaking of which this movie has kind of
gone viral before it's even come out
because of Megan's dance moves what has
that been like it's been like awesome
it's just the coolest thing honestly we
you know you make a movie you come up
with the marketing campaign and you just
hope it like takes off you hope it
resonates but you have no idea what's
gonna happen like there's no way to
predict anything in this business and
then once we started seeing people
reacting to it on Twitter we were like
oh this is the best case scenario people
are having so much fun with her they
seem to understand like what her energy
was which was the best like she's a very
specific Vibe very specific kind of gal
or Megan and we knew that the mission
was as long as people like understood
her we were gonna be okay and so yeah
ever since I was little I dreamed of
this perfect toy that would protect a
kid from ever feeling lonely or sad this
is Megan Hi Megan I'm Katie
it's nice to meet you Katie do you want
to hang out
what is her vibe because she can I mean
she can dance she can drive here she's
like a fiercely protective best friend
you know those people who are like if he
does something to you I will kill him
she means it
she made this she means not an empty
threat with her I love that Megan has
already been starting beef with like
Chucky and Annabelle listen I hear this
and I'm like there's no beef like
there's no contest my girl has got it
she has the World Wide Web in her brain
like
she's got it all she's a leg up on
everyone I keep asking people I'm like
do you think that they would team up or
just all kill each other
oh interesting I think she would kill
both of them she's like there's not
enough room for all of us in this world
and she'd make quick work of it lastly I
want to ask you because
um Taylor Allison Swift she signs off on
everything and I'm just curious as EP
like did you have to be like can we use
your music and not personally ask her
although as a community of Allison's it
would have been possible I I'm so happy
we got to use the song because it is
just so perfect with that trailer
because it's so sweet and jaunty and
then we found a way to make it
terrifying and so I feel very grateful
and lucky congrats I take it Arlo is not
getting a mechan doll no one is getting
who Megan doll for Christmas that is a
bad idea
[Music]
foreign